okay so the I've talked before about how
the the program is constantly iterating
and changing and I want to be improving
the show and making the program
reflective not only of what I think are
important political issues but making
the format reflective of what people in
the audience enjoy and so we had some
questions that I asked last week about
interview duration and story duration
number of stories per day live calls
versus voicemails and I have the results
now hundreds and hundreds of people
emailed me some of the trends are very
clear and on some questions the audience
seems kind of undecided or at least
indifferent we could say so here are the
results from what we asked you about
last week
first of all should interviews be
reduced in number and extended in length
this was the most overwhelming result 73
percent of the audience wants a fewer
interviews that are longer 27% does not
want that change so that's a really
significant result should voicemails be
replaced with live calls the answer is
no eighty percent of the audience says
no no no keep the voicemails and don't
replace them with live calls should we
cover more stories per show it's almost
a 50/50 split forty five percent say
cover more stories per show 55 percent
say don't and then should each story be
longer in duration almost two-thirds of
you said yes extend the story's a bit a
little more than one-third as said no so
of some pretty significant numbers there
at least as far as people are going in
the direction of preferring longer form
content that seems to be the trend
wanting interviews to be longer and
fewer in number wanting stories to be
longer and roughly the same in number
based on these results some other common
requests or ideas that came from people
who got in touch one idea was cancel the
Friday classic interviews saying listen
David those interviews are available on
the YouTube channel it can sometimes be
interesting to sort of like revive
revive an old interview but we can find
them you could probably do something
better with that time also a lot of
requests for more of our deep dive
long-form segments which is something
we're considering and then also lots of
ideas about what I should be doing when
we launch on Twitch the David Pakman
show is in
very advanced discussions with twitch
and their partner team and some of the
ideas that people came up with are used
twitch just to take audience calls and
questions pull some of that stuff off of
the YouTube channel do it on twitch play
chess presumably against members of the
audience or not but do some playing of
chess even though I'm not that good I do
play chess I enjoy it I could do that on
Twitch show prep behind the scenes in
other words pull up a browser and
actually show how I go through the
research and preparation process for the
show show how I create my notes show how
I gather clips and quotes and charts
that I will be using on the program like
the next day for example interesting
idea pull up old david pakman show
videos and comment on them in other
words pull up like a video from six
years ago play it and then explore
whether my view has changed or it's the
same or whatever play Mario Brothers or
Tetris I guess people mentioning those
games because I play very few video
games but those are two that
historically I used to play take
political tests like the political
compat compass test and others as part
of these twitch streams or play my drums
which i would love to do but I don't
really have them properly miked right
now and just like ambient drum sound
onto a regular microphone is not the
best thing so those are all really great
ideas so here's what we're doing in the
immediate number one we are going to
start making some tweaks with regard to
interview and story length that are
reflective of what people want but for
everybody who says everything's fine no
need to worry there's not going to be
any massive changes or up ending of the
program it's just really little tweaks
to keep iterating and make the show the
best possible show for today's audience
demands and interest which have changed
over time understandably number two
there is something I want to let you
know about going on with twitch if you
have an Amazon Prime membership and I
know many people in the audience do you
get a free monthly twitch membership one
that you can use to sign up for the
channel of your choice normally that'd
cost five dollars a month but if you
have an Amazon Prime membership you are
gifted
a credit for one twitch membership per
month you can use that free twitch
membership eventually to support the
David Pakman show
on twitch okay so if you have an Amazon
Prime membership and you aren't
currently on twitch what I would ask you
to do to prepare for the launch of the
show on twitch is make an account on
twitch connect your Amazon Prime account
to your twitch account you can google
how to do that and then when the time
comes I will let you know when you can
assign your free your free be twitch
membership
thanks to being an Amazon Prime member
to the David Pakman show okay so you can
do that in advance just to prepare and I
will let you know when we were ready to
launch on that front